what are you thinking about I do what I
do because of my dad he was a hero
he'd gave his life for the pursuit of
knowledge control getting that over
[Music]
it's crazy out there there's fires
everywhere and plane crashes they're
calling it the surge major we have some
highly classified information what can
you tell us about the Lima project its
objective was to search for advanced
extraterrestrial life the ship
disappeared approximately 16 years into
the mission and the commander was it was
my father Sir this might come as quite a
shock to you
your father was experimenting with a
highly classified material that could
threaten our entire sources all life
would be destroyed we're counting on you
to find out what's happening out there
I'm worried about you I love you please
begin your psychological evaluation as
best you can please describe your
current mental and emotional state I am
feeling good ready to do my job to the
best of my abilities
I remain fully committed to the lawful
completion of the mission if necessary I
will destroy the project and its
entirety
the earth was hopes in him
and now it's fake it's on me
we have a job to do are you ready I'm
ready
you
[Music]
you